senior citizens like Isabella Moreira
have been using bottled water since
reservoirs in Uruguay's capital started
going dry public officials have decided
to use a mixture of ground and salt
water to overcome the shortage
The Taste is awful when you brush your
teeth you can taste the salty water it's
disgusting I tasted the salty flavor
while I was drinking yerba mate I said
to myself but the mate is horrible
what's wrong with it and I said it's
salty
the government says the tap water is
safe even though the amount of sodium is
now more than 400 milligrams per liter
that's twice the World Health
organization's recommendation
the salt is also damaging kitchen
appliances
chloride levels are also High double the
previous limits set by Health officials
tens of thousands in the capital have
been protesting
Uruguay's government has declared a
state of emergency in Montevideo it's
Distributing two liters of bottled water
a day for each of the more than half a
million low-income residents
but businesses such as ajitos
restaurants say they need 10 times that
amount to stay afloat
the coffees are made with mineral water
the preparation of the pizza also with
mineral water the fine and arrogant
chickpea flatbread with mineral water
all the products are made with mineral
water
the state-owned utility has taken
emergency measures it's constructing new
dams pumping stations and transferring
fresh water to reservoirs crews are also
drilling for new wells to find potable
water Paul chadurgian Al Jazeera